what's with everything getting shot down
out of the sky what's going on there huh
I know part of it is the media
everything's getting shot down out of
the sky remember the Chinese balloon
that got shot up they left first of all
they left it up in the air for like
weeks
so I'm like well okay
but then all of a sudden they shot it
down
because people were like what's the deal
with this balloon we don't know what's
going on
where's it from and then somebody's like
it's a Chinese thing
we don't really know and then they're
like okay we'll shoot it down and then
Biden was like
ah oh and then shot it down Weeks Later
so it's like
shoot it down away earlier if you're
gonna shoot it down shoot it down
immediately
know what we can't have balloons from
China be doing
Gathering Intel
so if you decide you're gonna shoot it
down shoot it down immediately before it
can gather Intel
whoops it's got the Intel
spin up for also things like technology
can gather Intel immediately so shoot it
down very quickly I'm talking about
get it
going
once you see a balloon
shoot it as a matter of fact we're
living in a world where if you see a
birthday balloon shoot it down because
it's just like we can't be having
Intel
be gathering
our Intel is for us so this is what this
means many things have been hovering
above America for a long time and now
it's a thing
so here's what I gotta say
I guess doesn't matter
they already got the Intel
shoot down whatever you want
doesn't matter at this point anything
that invades American airspace shoot it
down there's no people in it cap it let
me get talk to it what up homie if it's
unclear what the objects are they're bad
the White House is saying
hey guys
one thing's for sure and we just want to
let you know
it's not aliens
that's what you say when it's aliens I
do believe Joe Biden is a lizard and
goes into the ocean and sheds his skin I
don't want everyone getting you know
what it is not it's not aliens
or I was lying now you're this tall
because they shrink you crazy crazy
[Music]
congratulations